so now what we'd like to do is try to
understand how to apply the law of
addition of velocities so we can express
the velocity to the point on the rim in
the reference frame fixed to the ground
now the important thing to realize is V
is the velocity of the center of mass of
the wheel with respect to the ground and
every single point on the wheel has that
same velocity V so let's draw a picture
of our wheel here we're in the ground
reference frame and let's first draw
four points on the wheel and draw this
velocity V every single one of these
points has the same velocity V be V and
V now let's add to that the velocity of
a point of the rim as seen in the
reference frame moving with the center
of mass we just saw that every single
point on the wheel is undergoing
circular motion in that reference frame
so now let's draw those velocities I'll
just draw it right below BC MP down here
BC MP notice here it's in the opposite
direction BC MP and up here it's
pointing up so when we add these two
vectors together what we get is a longer
vector in this direction it would be the
sum of these two pieces so we point like
that
that's DP over here it's the vector
decomposition so it's in that direction
here it's a shorter vector VP and over
here it's the vector sum VP so now what
we've been able to do is describe the
velocity of the point P as a combination
the vector addition of how the center of
mass of the wheel is moving and the
circular motion as seen in a reference
frame moving with the center of mass now
what we want to explore is
special conditions which will refer to
as rolling without slipping slipping or
sliding